[Music]
shadow of Mordor was a fantastic game
that came in last year in fact it picked
up GameSpot's Game of the Year award and
they believes in a bunch of DLC over
Christmas and beyond and the latest one
I think it's the last one just came here
today Alexa ray Korea expert on all
things Tolkien in the office you've been
playing it since yesterday what do you
think about this expansion that is
basically sort of fixing the ending of
the game so so the problem with the
problem with the ending of shadow of
Mordor is the final boss is essentially
a QuickTime event yeah bunch of
QuickTime events and you don't actually
get to fight Sauron the whole game is
sort of like go against Sauron so the
what this does is it gives you an entire
new campaigns about ten missions long
and you're fighting as Kellie Rynn boar
who is who is the ghost that's attached
Italian to kill the Wraith powers but
he's still alive in this version before
all that stuff happens it spoilers if
you haven't played before guys um he is
the bright Lord yes Sun was bright Lord
um Smeagol was referring to him as right
he um it's the name
I think bright bright Lord is an an
epithet that monolith has ascribed to
him but Kelvin boy in the Lord of the
Rings in Lord the Rings floor is the
forger of the rings of power he Sauron
pretends to be a good guy basically and
shows up at his home and it's like hey
let's make some jewelry and come on
Barry yeah he's a master craftsman
so he's like sure yeah I'll make some
jewelry yes let's do it so they were six
carry we make Cities rings that are
super powerful and of course Alexa for
anyone who doesn't know is a scholar of
Cole I am a scholar of chokan I went to
college for this stuff um and I heard
about video games uh the whole premise
is that monolith took that relationship
with Sauron and Caliburn war and Sauron
does in the books trick kellerman bore
into making the One Ring
like by accident but what monolith has
done is they sort of made it so that
Kelly renoir is sort of forced into it
and at the last minute pulls back and as
you can see he has the ring like he
steals the ring from Sauron literally if
you watch he watched the cutscene he
literally like saurons holding any pokes
his finger in the ice sorry
white with it I'll do it so Kellerman
war is using the ring to do the same
thing Dalian was doing in shadow of
Mordor which is subjugate these orcs
yeah and it's interesting because the
bright Lord focuses on domination rather
than killing so you have a whole new set
of nemesis the Nemesis system you have
five new war Chiefs thank you playing in
the first section or the second section
of mortals you're in the first map okay
and it's pre-fall Mordor which you can
see by all of this new gritty grit yes
and darkness and sometimes Sauron will
talk to you and the edges of the screen
will go red cuz Ahrens talking you know
it's a piece of [ __ ] yeah basically so
new war Chiefs you have to dominate all
of them there's five um
the interesting thing is in the original
in the main game you could go in and
essentially take out a war Chiefs
bodyguards one by one and make him a
weaker so he has no protection you can't
do that in the bright Lord because
you're only dominating them because you
can only dominate them and you can't
take out the bodyguards like like you
can't you can't take them out you can't
take them out first you have to go after
them like immediately so it's you
against these war Chiefs who start at
level 20 so they're already very very
difficult so you can't done so what I
did you know and I think the last
portion of shadow water was you had to
you dominated the war Chiefs and then
you essentially just use them to replace
the existing works yes which was super
easy well this one needs a little so
doesn't you do that no like the whole
board like they're all level 20 they're
all very difficult um what you can do
which is something that I actually
really appreciate is you can dominate
the lower the lower or it's like you can
run through an area and they'll be like
having dinner and you'll be like mine
mine mine and now you have four guys how
cool and that adds to your existing
retinue of guys so if you're completing
a mission and you have to one really
hard mission was you have to be the big
group of orcs and you have to keep 15
branded orcs in your retinue for tool
for two minutes okay and the works that
are not serving you will kill the orcs
that are serving you so that number is
constantly going down so you have to
quickly brand more to keep them up and
if you get under I think 10 the count
resets the two minutes resets so that
sounds like a whole new like intentional
focus because one of the other things
you told me yesterday when you were
playing was that one of the like main I
guess attacks in the game that was so
handy and I kept upgrading was being
able to just fire arrows one by one by
one yeah slow the game down
yeah the slow-mo is gone there right
well most gone I talked to the design
director Michael de platter last week
and he told me that they removed that
slowdown because in Lord of the Rings
lore the elves are all very skilled with
bows and they're very quick with them so
it seemed pretty you know seemed like a
good idea to just take out that slow
down because Elle's just know how to do
it they just don't but she do you know
how to do when you're not controlling
and Alvin and I know it's missing and
the perspective goes into over it goes
like into almost first-person so it's
got really so it's got like a shooter
element to it now and you have to work
very quickly however your arrows are
more powerful you can one hitch one one
hit shoot an orc and then he's done I
think you can you know shoot from far
away and he's I think this guy need yeah
and you can dominate now with arrows as
well
excellent can swoop in and grab them um
so how are you actually enjoying it then
is it is it worthwhile is it an
essential thing to play if you were
finally get like I loved Mordor I kind
of would like any excuse to go back and
play it again like is it sort of an
essential addition to the game um I
would say I think it's very very
different it's a similar but different
experience to shadow of Mordor and it's
very it's very very difficult if you did
find in Mordor and you loved it and you
want more I think it'd be worth going
back and trying this out sort of offers
things from a different perspective and
you get to fight Sauron and you get
everything from Kelvin Wars point of
view and whereas tallien was sort of
like you sort of felt for him Kelvin bar
is actually kind of he's almost a little
nasty like she's very very like like
crude and a little crazy um but I like
it I really like it I'm not quite done
with it but I like that it's offering
that sort of a challenge excellence I
mean ya feel like Mordor I'd go back to
it fantastic well in one thing for did
you start with all of your powers
because I felt like when I was playing
shadow Mordor was a lot of fun like it
was a good challenge and they got to the
end where it's like oh my god this is
like I'm just oh yeah I'm basically
jumping over people ranking them and
then I just have an army of Orcs who are
doing all of the killing for me yeah so
does it meet fit is a feel harder after
that studied that envis a little - yeah
no you felt very icy - out of Mordor I
think we all felt pretty powerful on you
start brightlord Kell
boar's all his skills are unlocked you
have all of them available to you
however when I was talking earlier about
how you have to sort of focus on
dominating the works in the Nemesis
system instead of killing them if you
kill them you get runes for your weapons
which are the only things you can
upgrade but if you're focusing on
dominating you can't kill them so you
have to sort of make decisions like
depending on who you're killing like do
I kill this measly little guy for like a
for like 18% health upgrade or do i
dominate them will that help me in the
long run and I kind of I liked that
about the first game and I sort of liked
that here but ya know you have
everything you are ready to go out
against our freight Lord you are the
bright Lord excellent ready to go alexxa
thank you so much for coming on yeah and
tell us all about that I'm gonna pick
that up later on that's available to day
for the general public please let us
know what you think about that of course
game spots game of the year for 2014
shadow of Mordor in the comments below
[Music]